i got another game that we should play
let me bring chris back in
all right chris hi i'm just taking
i'm just taking notes on your banter oh
my god what a flex you got a laminated
script
it's a it's a notebook of notes wait are
you on a green screen oh you're on the
green screen background with your father
on the phone call still
my father taking a call uh who is still
alive
but the age of this photo it could be
like oh don't make fun of it because
like he could be passed on no he's
definitely alive
and he looks pretty much the same all
the hair is gone
which let me know my hair was gonna be
gone and sure enough
there we go yeah
some people can't yeah i can't put a hat
on my head's too good well i
i like i like just wearing hats and then
when you start losing your hair people
think you were wearing it
to cover up the fact that you're losing
hair but me i'm very com
i love being involved because i have a
bald head head
you know what i mean yeah with that yes
i know i have two horns you have two
horns
just like yeah but they they're like
curly kids like two pigtails
uh you ever seen a pig's tail that's
like a little curly have two of those
but
it's solid bone that tiny ram that's
very nice
the doctor said i should not be uh
allowed to be alive
yeah i agree with your doctor and but
you know
you you overcome such a conversation for
people that have not
talked to anyone else today like this is
completely the first person you've
talked to
like you never take like a shitty
general i have to like call my
girlfriend and be like hey this is what
human beings say
i want to play a game with you guys it's
impossible to get off of a
zoom call i mean there's no really
polite way to do it that i have
yet to find because there's no excuse
you can't
you know you can't get off it's like i
have something to do everyone knows you
have nothing to do
so we're going to play a game called
escape the zoom
based on escape the room from 2016's
hottest attraction uh so you'll have a
certain amount of time to
try to get off of a zoom call with me
in a polite way so
it can't be overly rude but you do have
to get off of the call i'm gonna do
everything in my power to keep you on
the call
uh being emotionally abusive so well
we'll start with rachel and dan you guys
are trying to wrap
up uh zoom call with me
oh yeah no um no i just been making like
sourdough i got a sourdough starter kit
and you know it's just about like
putting the time and i guess you get
you get better do you hear the baby i do
actually speaking of sourdough i think
our baby's poop smells like sourdough so
we we gotta go change her diaper oh i
would love to see the baby
there's no photos of the baby on the
internet bring the baby in it's not a
problem at all
i'm an expert at changing the baby is uh
covered in
[ __ ] now and um oh it's gonna take a
while
to clean this happened to me wednesday i
that i am no
liner to this i fell in the tub and i
like to poop in the tub
she'll be pee in the shower i'd poop in
the tubs it's all the same it's all
pipes
uh you're just bringing it it's totally
fine no no
it'll get it'll get [ __ ] like it'll get
[ __ ] everywhere
and uh and you know if you were here you
could help but but you obviously can't
help so we just we're just going to go
we gotta
i think i think spread it around they're
saying that there's a lot of stuff in
manure and stuff that could actually
nobody's saying oh no and also like her
her [ __ ] is like it's
yellow like mustard it's not like actual
[ __ ] listen i've seen
way worse things on my hard drive the
things i say
maybe is like losing she's losing she's
losing her mind right now
we gotta go i put audiences to sleep i
can put a baby to sleep
but she doesn't need to sleep she's
covered in [ __ ] like in fact it would be
if she went to sleep covered in her own
[ __ ] she might suffocate on her own [ __ ]
right now every second you talk to us
makes us worse parents
um so i really gotta go listen then
let's get more eyes on this it takes a
village they say so let's i'm here to be
that village for you
yeah you know i've just been thinking
about you know different cultures
and what i can do to help you know i
just always
feel like i it's not your job you
shouldn't be thinking about that yeah
so outcome yeah you're right so what did
you guys love like after
after having a baby i mean when you're
you're back to having a bag
bye oh that's rude i feel right now
okay that's how you get off of a zoom
call so chris
any notes for them anything that was
rude
uh i think that they were lovely it was
very hilarious
i am very worried about that [ __ ] coming
baby
right i'm in the wrong in that situation
what a way to sell your baby out yeah
and also this guy is selling his sadness
right gram's asleep i put babies it
takes i'm a very
i was also covered in [ __ ] at some point
so chris same thing you have
uh and you're very good at this you do
this all the time to me
um you have a certain amount of time to
get off of
a zoom meeting with me
i guess this one's a general we were
talking about upcoming projects
yeah so snapchat's doing a lot of great
things right now you know
i mean there's a lot of harassment there
but it's just about
you know finding the right people there
and i'd love to bring you in
for a snapchat i would love i would love
to be a part of that
so i think we should circle back man um
yeah no i've been circling you for a
while for this project
yeah and it's kind of like it's like me
and you
talking right and you kind of just are
explaining
racism to me you know okay and other
white people like what what is the big
deal why are people on the streets
what's your actual number so i can let's
keep things professional right now and
just on zoom i'll i'll have
uh my assistant which is actually just
me with a different email
uh reach out with the phone number oh
great yeah cool they have a style and
i'll reach it back out
once you reach out and then we'll circle
back we'll reach around you know we'll
get
we'll get it done absolutely and i i
want to talk to you about
my experience at the black lives matter
protest and and
that's gary westbrook me to be outside
you know it was so oh you frozen what is
oh what's going on no i got you uh
i i still see you can you hear me can
you hear me
you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna start
it over i'm gonna reset it
oh i'm gonna reset it okay can you hear
me yeah i think i think just keep
talking because i was about to go into
my idea so
if you can hear me that's fine okay
oh that's his crotch and i'm off i'm off
zoom
he got out oh he left that was good oh
that was good legitimately out and
that's a real problem for the show we
don't have the
actual technology outside of the show to
bring him back on
oh chris really really was so polite
he entertained some of the worst ideas
one of the most problematic you had so
many thoughts on racism
and black lives matter that like other
people would have just
given you the middle finger and he
really listened as if
your opinion matters
so i think our winner of the game let's
put it in the chat who do you think won
this one
saying a lot of stuff for chris that was
a hard stance
i actually i think what i'm saying now
chris is our winner i mean
if you disagree with me put it in the
chat let's shatter this family
rachel blue dan greger new baby they're
winners man
they got the baby thank you guys so much
for for taking the time out
on a very real note uh rachel it's
really nice to talk to you and i
appreciate you taking this time uh dan
as well man it's great to see you
this is great and congratulations on the
on the new baby
it's uh what a time you've been through
so thank you so much for being here
yeah chris redd thank you so much as
always
appreciate you being here man uh this is
great uh these shows have been
honestly more fun than i thought so
thank you guys so much for joining us
for moses and friends we'll be back for
another one because why not this is
great
all right stay safe good night i'm about
to call moses right after this yeah i
know
listen i got notes on your personality
yeah you gotta really tone it down